mister jones professeur associé de
politique l'université de montfort de
leicester c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir à leicester
jones perd 6 d'être avec toi en direct
sur rt france boris johnson qui ressort
donc vainqueurs de ces élections avec un
sièges supplémentaires à la chambre des
communes le parti conservateur qui était
encore en difficulté 1 il ya peu
pourrait être le parti de demain le
parti de l'avenir du parti conservateur
effectivement réussi à tirer beaucoup de
soutien et cette élection partielle
montre que pour exister toujours très
important pour les britanniques avec les
vaccinations bien sûr donc la campagne
de vaccination marche très bien et
johnson endosser toute la responsabilité
de ces victoires ville
il a donc beaucoup de bonne volonté dans
le pays envers lui et il espère que cela
va continuer ces plaintes a indiqué dans
le discours de la reine le discours du
trône montre qu'il a beaucoup d'idées
mais qui ne coûte pas grand chose pour
le moment
alors quand ton parti travailliste un
mot sur lui quand même avec son ancien
leader jeremy corbyn tenu responsable de
la déroute électorale des législatives
de décembre 2019
aujourd'hui c'est écrire star mais qu'il
espère faire remonter le parti pourquoi
cela n'a pas fonctionné
le problème pour les partis travailler c
est le président d'une part égale un la
vaccination
le parti travailliste a du mal à lutter
contre le parti conservateur car il est
très difficile de lutter contre la
campagne de vaccination le parti
travailliste cependant a beaucoup gagné
mais on n'aura pas beaucoup parler dans
la presse
de nouveaux maires par exemple dans des
régions
de tout temps le terrain tu étais ont
été gagnés ou a maintenu par l le parti
travailliste mais il ya eu cette
réaction générale sur le fait qu' ils
ont perdu plusieurs sièges
il faut savoir que le parti conservateur
a perdu beaucoup de sièges dans le sud
au vert au profil du parti travailliste
mais pour le moment le parti
travailliste se concentre sur les
mauvais résultats
alors que dans certaines régions du
pénible il leur stratégie a bien
fonctionné
elles ont cependant mis qu il ya eu des
victoires et des défaites
n'oublie souvent c'est que ces élections
assez des élections locales
pour des problématiques locales étudie
la même stratégie il étudie l'impact sur
les régions centrales et oublie tout le
niveau local alors entre dossier à les
deux parties écossais favorables à
l'indépendance ont renforcé leur
majorité au parlement d'edimbourg cette
semaine et souhaite désormais
l'organisation d'un nouveau référendum
le premier ministre lui y est opposé un
britannique
quelle peut être l'issue de ce dossier
épineux vient constitue cuche de
constitution si west mister refuse à
l'heure c'est dossier clou car le
référendum est humble je vois un run du
gouvernement tous les référendums
doivent se faire à westminster en
angleterre et les verts écossais
souhaite effectivement un référendum
indépendant il pourrait en organiser un
simon s'agirait que d'un référendum
consultatif s'il voulait un référendum
contraignant alors oui ce booster
devrait organiser donc un court terme
rien ne va changer le smp les verts vont
exprimer leur volonté de référendum mais
ne pourront pas en organiser le court
terme et c'est de se préparer sur le
référendum est de sortir de l'appareil
qu'ovide si l'on regarde les résultats
entre les personnes pour et contre le
référendum
il ya une division 50 50 en écosse une
moitié de l'ecosse à voter pour des
partis pro indépendance et d'autres pour
des parties de réunion une écosse est
divisée donc fait de la question et
quand faudra-t-il organiser le
référendum
je ne pense pas qu'il y ait que la star
jeunes va essayer pour les 18 mois voire
deux ans à venir aux cours en tout cas
de ce mandat parlementaire
elle a assez de temps pour amasser
encore plus de soutien populaire et avec
un peu de chance on pourra organiser un
référendum qui sera dit orieux mais le
temps en politique que s'écoulent très
vite donc il faut attendre
merci beaucoup listériose professeur
associé de politique à l'université de
montfort de leicester d'avoir été avec
nous